rich mckay the chair of the competition
committee aboard that you're a member of
has said that there definitely won't be
replay review of past interference this
year
do we know or do we have an idea of what
will take its place will there be
anything to prevent another rams saints
nfc championship game outcome or will it
just be rely on the referee and the rest
of the officiating crew to get it right
when there is or isn't pass interference
there's options that we're going to be
reviewing i don't think because of uh
you know this unprecedented uh situation
where we're not able to meet and spend
the time the competition usually does on
all the unintended consequences that
come with solutions uh we really build a
lot of things this year
because what we don't want to do is make
a decision that does have unintended
consequences that aren't in the best
interest of the game we know we got a
great game i just don't do anything uh
you know that hadn't been well thought
out
stephen jones not just a cowboys
executive but a member of the
competition committee chris the group
that will be
devising something for the owners to
consider as the alternative to replay
review for pass interference it's dead
it's gone it's not even going to be
presented as an option it was a one year
and one year only experiment but they
need something otherwise we are setting
the stage for another rams saints
debacle where there is an egregious
instance of past interference that
happens in plain sight
that is missed by the seven folks in
black and white stripes who are charged
with the task of catching it when it
happens now stephen jones said they have
options
now then the biggest option is sky judge
but i've never gotten the impression
they want to they want to spend the
scratch necessary for scott judge or
they also and also it's not just a
matter of being extremely careful with
money it's a matter of
being sure that your 17 sky judges
all will have the same standard for when
to intervene
when to supersede when to make opinions
known to the officials on the field that
something was missed based on what we
see in the camera angles that are
broadcast to the same tv screens that
the rest of us have at home so there's
no easy solution here they need to avoid
what happened in the ram saints game
and i don't know what the most efficient
solution would be because as stephen
jones said
all of these possibilities have
unintended consequences and we saw the
unintended consequences last year of
having replay review available for past
interference chris yeah well all right
so first off i mean let's not forget
this was a one-time thing we saw in 53
years in the nfl it's that we we can't
really come up with too many whoa that
was totally egregious how could you do
that type moments how could you miss
that and a big moment of the football
game no this was wrong i get it i will
say i'm glad the past interference
replay is dead thank god i mean it's
disaster it's horrible for the sport it
was a bad look you know first off it
messed up the football games as a viewer
just the way it was slowed down you
didn't know what to expect wait that
looks like past interference that does
it we could never agree watching the
games at nbc you know it didn't seem
like the nfl ever knew what the hell
the call either at times it was a little
inconsistent that way you know you had
coaches wasting challenges because oh
hey i'm a coach and i've been a head
coach for 20 years that looks like fast
interference i'm gonna throw the
challenge fight what it's not oh now
you've lost a challenge flag and a
timeout and that's gonna hurt your you
know ability to manage the football game
from that standpoint so i think there's
more negatives than positives but with
saying all that mike i do agree with you
they got to have something whether
that's you know again like the the big
red button back at 3 45 that they can
hit on when there's a danger or
you know can you watch all those moments
and really react to them real time if
there's all these games going on and
that's where i think your sky judge
comes into play to where like okay al
riverand's trying to watch everything if
one of these egregious plays happened
and maybe he's in the middle of a review
somewhere else you know sky judge can
hey this is red alert red alert al river
on red alert red alert we have a play we
need you to we might need you to get in
and tell the refs to drop a flag or do
whatever there does need to be something
like that i do think to protect the nfl
here
i think the concept is very simple and i
have said this time and again the nfl's
biggest problem from an officiating
standpoint is the gap that exists
between what seven people who are on the
field amid the gladiators with no
protection of any kind where the primary
goal is to not get trampled and the
naked eye does not process the
information the way that it could or
should because these guys can move
quickly and when you're trying not to
get trampled it makes it even harder to
spot exactly what it is you're seeing if
you have someone
in that booth who is the fan see
bridging the gap between what those
seven people see in an imperfect setting
versus what we see at home in an ideal
setting
4k hd supersize slo-mo we all see it
the gap between what we all see
and what they see on the field gets
bridged by getting chris and this is
very simple i think you pay the money
for the salary but all these guys who
are going off to work for networks like
like
uh
terry mike herrera and
mike pereira and and dean blandino
doesn't count because he was never on
field uh who's the guy gene sterritor
all the guys who leave to go get a
better payday and lesser accountability
with the networks that can be the guy
ad hocule right you get to a point where
you need to retire because you're
physically unable to keep up with the
gladiators anymore 65 70 whatever the
case may be but you still have a sharp
brain and you still have the ability to
look at a tv and see what you see
those folks who know the rule books
inside and out they're the surrogates
for the fans who are sitting at home
saying what the hell are these officials
thinking that's the way to do it and
there should be
17 of those folks available in any given
year who they can pay to fill this job
it's almost like the the ombudsman for
the fan the person who is there who
knows the rule book who sees what the
fans sees that's how you meld the two
together and get to a point where we
avoid these outcomes it's that simple
chris it won't be cheap but it is that
simple
well maybe it's something we just have
for playoff football maybe maybe that's
really where it should count because to
me that's where one of the issues lies
within our officiating in the nfl
anyways you know in playoff football we
have seen
a very
consistent thing happened i want to say
for the last six or seven years where in
playoff football the games are just not
as officiated as much as the regular
season games now i understand you know
we have the best of the best referees in
the playoffs and the teams are better
and all of that
but you know i'm a guy like you know we
make fun of all time i'm ron jaworski
and i watch the film all right i don't
care if the teams are better or not when
i turn on the film and play off football
there is a lot more latitude given
towards secondary and past interference
and holding and just the physical nature
of the sport like jedevian clownies hit
to carson wentz if that's week seven in
the regular season i think it gets
called i think in the playoffs referees
are afraid to get involved in those type
of situations and they back off i think
that's what happened in the saints rams
game i think that's really all it was
you see the referee in the back first
off grabbing his flag i think he's going
wait do i really want to determine who
goes to the super bowl here with me
throwing my flag also i think to the
added factory he goes
he probably was shocked because he was
like wait nicole roby-coleman should
have caught that and ran for a pick six
if he just looked up it was such a weird
play all together but uh i i don't know
i don't know if you can can you pull it
off
all regular season all those weeks is it
just the playoff thing but they need to
have somebody there to watch over it a
little bit
i think you have to do it in the regular
season because you don't want the folks
who serve as sky judge to be starting
from scratch in the wild card round and
you want to you you look and then to
make it even better for the playoffs you
have people do it all season long and
then you grade them you judge them you
judge the sky judges and the best of the
best end up getting the playoff
assignments just like they do with the
officials so i think it needs to be
every game
preseason regular season so it's
perfected by the time we get to the
postseason and we know who the
best hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports